et le président russe vladimir poutine
suit la situation de près selon la porte
parole du kremlin
mais très peskov pour l'instant rien de
précis n'est envisagée nous n'excluons
toutefois pas une rencontre possible
autour de la question du libre
comme vous le savez quand il le juge
nécessaire messieurs poutine hier de
gamme prennent rapidement la décision
d'organiser une rencontre les change
récents entre les deux présidents a
prouvé que chaque partie avait ses
propres préoccupations
nous nous inquiétons principalement du
fait que les groupes terroristes
continuent de se concentrer à idlib dans
la zone relevant des responsabilités
turbie
c'est dans cette zone que les
terroristes poursuivre leur activité
agressive qui visait les forces armées
de la république arabe syrienne ainsi
que les installations militaires russes
sur le sol syrien
les contacts au plus haut niveau se
poursuivre